[موسيقى]
صوت الحربي لا يتوقف في مدينه بخموت
الانفجارات لكثرتها لم تعد تجفل القله
الباقيه هنا
سري يسر على التمسك بما يشبه اليوميات
يطعم الكلاب الهائمه
[موسيقى]
يا زلمه
نهر بخمودكا يقسم المدينه الى جزئين الجسر
الواصل بينهما دمر تماما معيقا حركه
الاليات العسكريه والمدنيين في ان
على الجانب الاخر من هذا الجسر يقع الجزء
الشرقي من مدينه بخمود السكان يطلقون عليه
اسم المنطقه الرماديه نستطيع ان نسمع صوت
المدفعيه والرشاشات الثقيله الجانب الروسي
يحاول السيطره على هذا الجزء ما الجانب
الاوكراني فيقول انه مستعد لمعركه طويله
كي لا تفلت المدينه من تحت قبضته
القصف على بخموط بدا ايار مايو الماضي
اشهر القتال حولت ابنيه الى هياكل فارغه
بواجهات مدمره ومن بقي عليه النجا بلا
كهرباء ولا غاز ولا ماء وبلا تدفئه لذا
اصبح هذا المكان مقصدا هنا يتم تقديم
الطعام والشراب ويمكن شحن الهواتف واحيانا
الاتصال بالانترنت
فقط عندما يغطي الجليد الطرقيه
اكثر من 90% من سكان بخموت ترك المدينه
وبقي الارهاق رفيقا لمن استمر بالعيش طوعا
او قصرا فيها